we begin with this Hawaii officials face
widespread criticism this morning over a
false alarm warning the public of an
imminent missile attack people across
the state ran outside searching for
places to hide the head of the FCC which
is investigating calls the error
absolutely unacceptable at 8:07 Saturday
morning more than 1 million cell phones
in Hawaii began buzzing with a message
saying seek immediate shelter this is
not a drill
Saint officials canceled the alert at
8:13 six minutes later but they didn't
send a new cell phone message for
another half an hour until 8:45 David
Wagner went inside the command center
where the mistake happened he is in
Honolulu David good morning good morning
oops this was the front page headline
after that mistake happen and the agency
that made a mistake is now investigating
exactly what happened the governor says
the employee who pushed the wrong button
not once but twice feels terrible about
what happened he hasn't been fired in
fact he's being welcomed back to work
but not in the same job the panic was
palpable Hawaiians rushing for cover
under the threat of a missile attack
this child was lowered into a manhole
another family huddled in a closet 5,500
people called Honolulu's 911 it's
embarrassing but again again it's a
mistake
Hawaii's emergency management
administrator Vern Miyagi says one of
his employees click the wrong button
twice he was supposed to select the
option for a drill instead he clicked
the real thing this was the alert heard
by people across the island chain a
missile may impact on land or sea within
minutes this is not a drill with all due
respect are you sure this was an
accident yes I know the individual this
was an accident
but why did he hit yes twice that's
being talked about him being
investigated right now this is the state
warning point it was here that the
mistake happened the man who's been
working for the agency for about ten
years was sitting in this chair when he
pushed the wrong button
he realized within the first two to
three minutes we're told that he had
made a mistake but it took nearly 38
minutes to get another text message
alert out saying false alarm it is an
epic failure of leadership Hawaii
congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard was one of
the
to correct the error on Twitter 38
minutes of Terror for the people of
Hawaii before this message went out
saying sorry false alarm
I don't usually panic and know what tom
was far from his wife and children when
the alert was first issued I thought I
could do something and yet I felt
totally helpless at the same time so I'm
sitting there just kind of bawling my
eyes out
in the aftermath people across Hawaii
were confronted with this question what
would you do if this was the real thing
so wake-up calls it hey wait a minute I
don't know what to do our opportunity
right now is to reach out and get that
information to other people you know it
took 38 minutes to correct the first
tweet because what they actually had to
do was they had to get an IT guy at home
to compose a message then put a template
in the system and then get a new alert
out saying hey guys false alarm
now that template actually exists it's
ready to go it's not gonna take 38
minutes for the time being though the
governor says I don't want you guys
practicing this anymore and when you do
start practicing again I want two people
to be involved in every test amazing
thank you David